italian heritage philly tradition with
vegas flavor that's how you could
describe osteria fiorella at red rock
they're known for their pastas and
pizzas and delicious desserts here to
show us one of the house favorites is
pastry chef ashley costa welcome thank
you thank you so much it's so nice to be
here it's great to have you here so what
makes your desserts so special honestly
it's this ingredient right here salt
salt salt that's it salt that's it it's
the balance you want to find the balance
and what are you going to make for us
today so today we're making a crostata
de fruta costara de fruta yes fruit
fruit i got it exactly what do we need
it is a fruit tart puff pastry right
here
and you guys make these all in house we
do we make puff dough in house and then
it's filled with a cream fresh fruit
and then this one is going to get a
drizzle of raspberry reduction and candy
pistachio let's start assembling so
obviously you need to take one of these
right here well we're going to glue it
to the plate oh glue it to the plate and
also as we're making this tell me the
back story of the name of the restaurant
so osteria means like hang out yes in
italian and then fiorella fiorella is a
sausage factory back in philadelphia ah
okay that mark fetchery bought yes back
in philly and he
changed it into a pasta bar and it just
went crazy in philly so he brought that
concept here so now we're here so now
we're here at red rock this is perfect
so i'm going to glue it down on the
plate here so it doesn't move hold it in
place hold it in place and then we're
going to do some blueberry conserva a
little jam looks so good yes we make all
of our stuff in-house it's very seasonal
and then we like to save the berry
compost for the winter time to have
something
in the winter time when everything is
just citrus now you're such an amazing
pastry chef and i've heard so many
wonderful things about you and i also
heard that many people go to the
restaurant just for your desserts alone
as they should yeah they work very very
well come on in and just have the
desserts we do we work very hard and
we're putting more of the uh yeah we
call it glue but it's not glue clear
it's a pistachio cream oh i like this
nacho cream it's made with sicilian
pistachios
and then i have a great team i work with
we
change it seasonally very it's gorgeous
thank you i love it you know unlv grad i
have some skills from the college days
perfect
so now that that's fully arranged we're
just going to top it with fruit now the
best thing about this
what i love is that right now it's the
end of summer so you're getting all this
beautiful fruit it looks so good so it's
the best time to do a fruit tart do you
have to go like if someone's watching
right now they want to swing by and get
some your desserts and take a medium at
home do you offer to go services
absolutely yes we do and it happens
quite a bit especially during brunch
time if they want a cruffin or a cookie
or whatnot and what's this right here we
got to wrap it up here what's this here
that is the pistachio focat that's the
focaccia that we do can i take this home
with me now that i touched it absolutely
oh this is perfect this is a meal for a
couple days i appreciate it so much
ashley thank you for joining us sure
thank you so much for having me all
right las vegas now we will be right
back